n
danger la station spatiale
d'expliquer.
- C'est arrivé dans la nuit
de lundi, à deux reprises.
Les sept astronautes de la
Station spatiale internationale
ont dû se réfugier dan
parce qu'un nuage de débris
métalliques passait à proximité.
Le coupable : un tir de missile
russe qui a pulvérisé un vieux
satellite qui se trouvaitHier, s
étaient furieux.
l'OTAN en a rajouté.
La NASA a jugé que, parmi
les 15provenant
de l'explosion du satellite,
certains auraient pû croiser
la route de la S
de l'équipage, qui comprend
deux cosmonautes russes.
ANDRÉ GRANDCHAMPS astrophysicien
Planétarium Rio Tinto Alcan
une vitre de la Station spatiale
ou encore ça passe complètement
à travers, bien, ça peut faire
en sorte que l'air va s'écpas ce
de colmater la brèche,
bien, il faut évacuer.
- Il faut rappeler que ce n'ests
qu'une puissance spatiale
teste éricains, les Indiens
et les Chinois l'ont égalementfs
d'activités spatiales,
les débris se comptent déjà
craint de devoir cesser toute
forme d'activité en orbite en o,
par un effet de cascade, leur
nombre augmente encore plus.
ça crée des débris qui, eux,
vont être dangereux non pas
pour les heures qui suivent,
mais pour des années, mêmelà
vont rester en o
- Plusieurs systèmes
de réc
sont encore à l'étape des tests
ou de la planche à des
Mais c'est une solution
temporaire. Selon les experts,
l'utilisation de l'espace
sont absolument s
pour réglementer ces activités
hautement stratégiques.
allusion dans sa réplique à
Washina Russie aa Russie aa Russ
depuis des années de négocier
un traité destiné à prévenir
une possible course
Ici Normand Gro-Canada, M-CanaM